and i think an element of luck involved
and i will never
reject the opportunity for just good
old-fashioned fortuity the nfl to its
credit constantly looking
to tweak to revise to change the
protocols in order to
react to the way that the pandemic is
unfolding and for the first time we've
seen the nfl
make a change
on a rule that it previously had put in
place this is the 62 player limit for
game days it started as a reduction of
the travel party and the thinking was if
we're going to have the road team down
to 62 players to have competitive
balance the home team can only have 62
players present at the games and i was
told last week that there's a problem
with this potentially when you start
forcing teams to leave guys behind
then they potentially end up in
situations where they're exposed to the
viruses an argument to be made it's
better to have them with the team it
reduces
their risk of exposure and the risk of
an outbreak so the nfl to its credit you
know
one of the worst things you can do if
you make a mistake
is double down the nfl reversing course
and saying
we're not going to continue with the 62
player limit they recognize there's
value in having those players with the
team in the team hotel that's one of the
requirements you have to be at the team
hotel the night before the game to be at
the game the next day this is just one
less opportunity typically on a saturday
night for a guy to be doing something
that could get him exposed to the virus
sharing
yeah absolutely mike and the other thing
it does also is give teams more
flexibility it's up to them how many
players they travel with and if they
want to travel with however many then
they'll have those options available to
them
90 minutes before the game starts so i
think it's a great thing i think it's a
great change we've seen a lot of these
moves by the nfl this season because
they've had to show flexibility because
they didn't know what this season was
gonna entail and so they've made moves
based on what they've learned about the
virus moving forward and i think that's
good i'm with you you can't just sit
here and say well we're gonna continue
with these rules because these are the
rules we put in place at the start of
the season this isn't a normal season
you have to be flexible and they've done
that and kudos to the nfl and if they
get through this thing mike without a
week 18 i think we're all going to be
amazed but we certainly applaud the
efforts they've done to get through this
season
and one thing they're willing to do is
make changes even though it's possible
for some to say why didn't you do it
sooner why didn't you do it sooner you
should have done it sooner if you would
have done it sooner you wouldn't have
that outbreak or this problem or that
problem and i say that because the other
change that was communicated to the
teams in a memo dated december three
from now on
the two days after a game whenever the
game is if it's monday game tuesday
wednesday if it's sunday monday tuesday
etc two days after a game facility is
dramatically restricted to access
coaches can be in their own offices they
can't meet there can be no meetings
players can come in for treatment and
exercise but there are limits on how
many of them can gather and where they
can gather i always have to be in a
place where there are surveillance
cameras so there can be monitoring of
whether or not the social distancing and
the mask wearing is respected but this
is an outgrowth of the measures that
were put in place this week monday
tuesday all facilities shut down because
of the concern that guys were around
others over the thanksgiving holiday i
think the nfl realized that it's a
pretty good deal i mean the first two
days of the week after a game are the
slowest let's go ahead and keep everyone
out do everything virtually you don't
need to be in the facility let's give
the facility a breather and then we
still do the testing in between you can
pick off some positives that way before
they ever get back in the building
that's smart and it should have been
done sooner but it's okay that they're
doing it now
yeah mike and at this point in the year
let's be clear about this too normally
this time of year a lot of teams do this
they don't have players come in on
monday and tuesday just because they're
worn down at this point in the season
they're trying to keep them fresh
playoff teams are trying to keep their
players fresh so they give them monday
and tuesday off unless they need medical
attention in the training room they're
not at the facility anyway normally tons
of teams do that and so this is a good
time of year to do it i think it's smart
for them to do it and it just
avoids contact between players among
players uh for two more days and and
really limits that down they're doing
what they can you still need practice
time obviously so they've got to get in
there and practice they can't do this
every day of the week but i think this
is really smart it still gives you on a
normal work day wednesday thursday
friday saturday in the building to
practice and do what you need you need
to do within those four days
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports